it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week we got some brand-new
titles that are sure to she dark souls
is back I just got done forgetting the
pain of Dark Souls 2 this is so cruel
delve into the crown of the sunken King
the first DLC of the Lost crowns trilogy
good luck relive the pain on the 22nd
also this week in games from the past
coming back to haunt us we revisit
rupture farms with oddworld new and
tasty out on ps4 abe's oddysee is back
but not just an HD with
three-dimensional graphics for ps3 ps4
and Vita but you're still playing on a
2d field so it's the same game you love
with nicer looks it comes to ps4 first
on the 22nd also this week it's super
tense with God's will be watching a
point-and-click thriller about difficult
and moral decisions choose between
eating your friends or starving to death
or confessing top secret information or
losing an arm take your anxiety
medication July 24th super quickly I'm
going to mention the walking dead season
2 episode 4 amid the ruins is coming out
in a plethora of platform starting on
the 24th but I don't want to give
anything away so I'm going to move on to
this happy family playing wii sports
club the game comes with all sports
including tennis bowling golf boxing and
baseball with purchasing options similar
to a gym you can buy a day pass for 2
bucks or unlimited access for 10 which
also gives you access to the sauna and
tanning booths for further details visit
gamespot's new releases page release
dates are based on retailer listings and
are subject to change see you next week